all right you're done let's take a look
at the solution just like in our content
provider tests we can use get content
resolver to query based upon the content
URI remember that the default location
entry content URI just passes all of the
parameters into the database so we can
easily construct a query containing the
location query to see if it is in the
database yet remember that the default
location entry content URI passes all of
the parameters into the database so we
can easily construct a query containing
the location setting to see if it is in
the database yet if it's not then the
query would return an empty set and we
should insert the new city name location
setting and coordinates together note
that we're calling that add location
method from inside doing background
which calls get weather data from JSON
we've uncommented out the test add
location function now we'll run our
tests and our tests all pass we're ready
to move on to the next step